my name is Marilyn cone and I'm
associate dean of the School of
Professional Studies and I'm delighted
to welcome you all tonight it's really
great to see this kind of turnout for
John's talk and I know that we will all
be very excited it's also such a varied
group I wanted to take a moment to tell
you a little about SPS with the School
of Professional Studies which will
explain why this is such a varied group
in some ways so our mission is to
provide academically rigorous
market-driven education across the life
cycle and that ends up involving a
number of things we have 14 master's
programs which always surprises people
and they range from things like applied
analytics and I know we have one of our
students here to bioethics negotiation
and conflict resolution sustainability
Enterprise Risk Management nonprofit
management sports management the number
two in the country believe it or not and
this is Columbia that's a pretty big
deal so and that's just a few but you
can sense what the range of programming
is in addition we provide certificates
in most of those programs as well as a
number of others we also we are home to
the universities auditing program to the
visiting Scholars Program to lifelong
learning and to a very robust high
school program in the summers that has
about 3,000 kids each year so there are
lots of arms to SPS and one of those is
working with the community it's working
with Columbia University with the New
York City Community the local community
to bring interesting programs to all of
our constituents and that's where this
fits in so I am going to that task
actually Falls to George Calder our oh
where did you go George who is our
director of community relations and yay
that's right
and I'm gonna turn this over to him and
he will introduce the formal program
thank you all for being here and enjoy
the evening thanks Marilyn and it really
is a pleasure to welcome such a big
group big and diverse group to this sold
out that featuring John Reddick Columbia
community scholar I wanted to just tell
you a little bit about the Columbia
community Scholars Program it's
administered by the School of
Professional Studies and Columbia's
office of government and community
affairs and the program enables
independent community-based scholars
access to Columbia courses services and
resources that allow them to work toward
the completion of an academic or
research project
John Reddick was actually in the first
cohort of community scholars after a PI
to conduct research on tonight's topic
ragtime to jazz time
Harlem's black and Jewish music 1890 to
1930 John has applied his knowledge of
Harlem's culture and architecture
towards work he has done with the
Heritage Heights Village Business
Improvement District the Apollo Theater
and Harlem one-stop he's worked on
public art and space projects at a
number of Harlem based organizations
including Abyssinian Development
Corporation the Ralph Ellison Memorial
Committee the Harriet Tubman square and
Frederick Douglass Circle among other
projects John has also served as
president of cityscape Institute and
held leadership positions at the Central
Park Conservancy he received a Bachelor
of Arts Bachelor of Science in
architecture from Ohio State University
and a Master of Architecture from BL
University before I turned the program
on to John I'd like to acknowledge Kevin
Brannon from the university's office of
government and community affairs and
Suzy Stein executive director of the
School of Professional Studies lifelong
learning both of whom worked with the
community Scholars Program I'd also like
to acknowledge one of our newest
staff members Yuri Pollack who is the
chief of staff at the School of
Professional Studies as of about a month
ago and with that said I'm delighted to
welcome John Redick